salve a tutti e benvenuti in pausa una
tipologia di video che consisterà nel
rovinarci l'infanzia prima di tutto come
vedete sono ridotto male questo perché
avevo in mente una cosa da fare sarà una
cosa tranquilla la cosa ci possiamo
rilassare
io e voi come se fossimo seduti sullo
stesso divano tutti insieme quindi sono
esattamente come voi che di solito
guardate i video io mi faccio bello la
barba il vestito giusto no voi guardate
i video in mutande spettinati io faccio
pausa in mutande spettinato senza doccia
senza farmi la barba e oltre a puzzare
di che si parlerà in pausa
l'idea è la stessa del video di the lady
cioè prendere i primi episodi di serie
tv e cartoni animati che non hai mai
visto e vederli mi sembra di aver
accennato in un vecchio video questo
discorso
praticamente i primi episodi soprattutto
dei cartoni animati
nessuno li ha mai visti delle persone
che conoscevo io ovviamente a scuola
tutti seguivamo le tartarughe ninja
tutti seguivamo i cartoni animati degli
anni 90 ma nessuno aveva mai visto il
primo episodio e quindi siamo qui con un
bel b b tozzo salute a guardarci insieme
il primo episodio di mila e shiro mila e
shiro era uno di quei cartoni ma ti che
guardavo costantemente mi piaceva la
tematica in quel periodo ho anche fatto
un anno di pallavolo mi piaceva le
storie mi piacevano i personaggi mi
piacerebbe animazioni e credo che abbia
una delle sigle dei cartoni animati più
riconosciute in assoluto grazie
soprattutto a cristina d'avena che qui
vediamo in una fotografia che ho fatto
in un backstage di un suo concerto
perché io sono vip e mi invitano i
backstage dei concerti di cristina
d'avena ma non perdiamo altro tempo e
guardiamo insieme il primo episodio di
mila e shiro
l'episodio a quanto pare inizia con la
colonna solo l'uscita direttamente da un
film di fantozzi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
veniamo subito introdotti a vediamo se
ricco di nomi nanì della squadra hikawa
genio yotobi finché non leggerò e
commentino sapo la risposta e nello
stesso momento anche ad uno dei
personaggi più fastidiosi di tutta la
serie l'unico bambino giapponese biondo
siccome ho solo una scaletta e non mi
sono voluto scrivere niente mandare
tutto impulso per fare questo tipo di
video non mi ricordo come si chiama per
comodità lo chiameremo il fratellastro
di mila e la mia voce non è per niente
un adulto che i vita un bambino no no
nel frattempo mentre mi fanno vedere le
immagini sportive dove tutti giocano a
quello che vogliono calcio baseball
pallavolo io ripenso alla mia scuola
dove non facevamo altro che giocare a
calcetto 24 ore su 24 e il bello che il
professore diceva dopo riscaldamento
potete fare quello che volete
io facevo quello che volevo stavo seduto
in panchina a guardare gli altri giocare
i giocatori di baseball intanto riescono
a fare una cosa rarissima nell'universo
bloccare una pallina da baseball su un
albero è probabile che in quell albero
ci siano anche due o trecento miei super
tele più o meno e chi ci potrebbe essere
appisolata su un albero se non la nostra
protagonista mila
salve
o questa musica probabilmente
addirittura più che della sigla mi fa
tornare alle medie e alle elementari
questo sono qui sono del titolo della
puntata che io pensavo fosse stato il
porno a farmi perdere le diottrie ma no
a quanto pare è stata la colorazione del
titolo delle puntate di mila e shiro e
come tutti i protagonisti dei cartoni
animati sportivi giapponesi presentiamo
i superpoteri della nostra mila può
correre giù dagli alberi tipo naruto può
saltare sui rami tipo l'alba del pianeta
delle scimmie è riuscita ad addestrare
un colombo di nome tafi
[Musica]
e come tutti i supereroi anche lei al
suo simbolo prendo da bere perché mi
devo preparare per la scena ve lo lascio
assaporare o mio dio un panna sulle
mutande e per celebrare il buon david
letterman che è andato in pensione ecco
la lista dei cinque nomi che potrei dare
a quelle mutande o una strana voglia di
bambù voglio adottarne uno a distanza
vvf dove f sta per fi e una specie in
via d'estinzione e dulcis in fundo a
panda piace
e quindi grazie alla sua colomba
addestrata tappi lei riesce a trovare il
suo fratellastro e solo in un contesto
come mille cielo sono riuscito a dire
questa frase è riuscire a
contestualizzarla e va a finire proprio
dentro la palestra in cui si sta
svolgendo la partita guarda la sua
famosa battuta al volo di rondine no no
no ti sei confondendo quello è
chiaramente il tiro impasto per la pizza
ma appena trovato sani e come è venuto
in mente come si chiamava c'è un piccolo
problemino deve piscia adesso non è che
possiamo pretendere una trama dal primo
episodio di un cartone animato non sono
sicurissimo di cosa cazzo stia
succedendo in questo momento qui si sta
giocando una partita bene subito grazie
ai capri è un maleducato a chi lo dici
mila vengono giustamente aggiungerei
sbattuti fuori dal campo e legati in uno
sgabuzzino
ok sono pronto a chiamare il 113 quando
volete voi ma a causa del lago di ppd
sunny che comunque è stato pulito c'è
proprio la scena dove lo puliscono le
giocatrici non riescono a concentrarsi
ben bene e si beccano un punto
[Musica]
vabbé nicchia 14 a 1 state vincendo ma
che sia tutto questo dramma non fatevi
ribaltare madonna recuperare per un
punto a casa di mila intanto qual è la
prima frase che dice sunny appena vede
uscire seminuda la sua sorellastra
milani è venuta fame
vai lontano
non ho nulla da aggiungere e scopriamo
anche che il padre di mila l'ha
abbandonata a causa lavoro e l'isi
ritrovarli completamente da sola caramel
non vedeva l'ora di riabbracciarti ma ai
miei impegni di lavoro in europa mi
terranno ancora per qualche giorno
lontano da te
vediamo anche che lei è partita da casa
dei suoi nonni insieme ataf rinchiuso in
una scatola da pic nic
ma sei completamente impazzita e subito
dopo inter lo si vede che lei che mangia
ma se non stai attento all'inquadratura
sembra che se si è mangiata taffi e
invece li nel sedile a fianco ma le
scatole sono uguali ma basta tutta
questa allegria
facciamo la conoscenza del figlio
illegittimo di hitler
l'allenatore dal fisico importante siete
riuscite a concedere un punto
all'avversario più debole del girone
dovreste vergognarvi
abbiamo vinto la partita che cosa gesù
le ha tirato uno schiaffo e l'ha
sbattuta a terra perché hanno ricevuto
contro un solo punto ma non per questo
devi sentirti autorizzate mettere bocca
quando io critico la squadra soprattutto
dopo la ridicola figura di oggi
il giorno dopo il primo giorno di scuola
ufficiale per mila e nella sua classe e
guarda caso indovina chi c'è la ragazza
di ieri a milano saluta nessuno io sono
sanitario ma cosa ci fa lì lui ma mi
spiegate cosa cazzo fa questo bambino
tutto il giorno per ora le uniche cose
che ha fatto e sono state pisciarsi
addosso allagare la casa e prendersi
talmente tante botte che se le ricorderà
per tutta la vita
ho sete ho finito il tè ma mila in
classe non si trova così bene come
avrebbe immaginato infatti in corridoio
incontra altre due pallavoliste bene si
può sapere cosa avete da guardarmi in
quel modo voi due siano della squadra di
pallavolo puoi venire una prima con noi
mi piace come le scuole giapponesi puoi
fare quello che vuoi tipo dei tu vieni
che andiamo in palestra sfidarci a
pallonate in faccia se l'avessimo fatto
noi ci avrebbero espulsi due secondi
dopo ma questo è il bello dei cartoni
animati giapponesi
siccome in campo c'è ancora un alone di
piscio incrostato blair sfidano mila a
10 schiacciate se lei riesce a prenderne
anche una sola non le fanno pulire la
palestra altrimenti pulisce la palestra
a quanto mi manca essere giovani e molto
stronzi droga
lei ovviamente alle prime battute non ce
la fa si prende delle pallonate in
faccia quasi arriva a prenderla ma per
un millimetro non c'e la parte del ceto
punto arriva sunny che riesce a prendere
una palla a cosa mariani ma in faccia e
muore ma non muore ci ho sperato per un
dio santissimo trovati qualcosa da fare
non puoi stare a rompere i [ __ ] alla
gente che passa non fare il solito
bambino non rompere le balle ma l'ultima
battuta è proprio la battuta forma di
pasta della pizza e ovviamente mila non
solo riesce a prenderla ma riesce anche
a saltare perché a quanto pare la
gravitas era andata in vacanza in quei
due minuti ea schiacciarle in faccia
bertani un vero per la vittoria e anche
se non si è fatto vedere durante questa
sceneggiata c'era anche l'allenatore e
la zucchi hai la stoffa di tua cugina
mimì o con un occhio di vetro
ma colpo di scena mentre mila esami
stanno tornando a casa chi ti incontrano
e proprio lui e furio di bianco rosso e
verdone codice fiscale carta d'identità
partita iva la somiglianza c'è tutta ma
è il papà di mila per me oggi inizia una
nuova vita piena di sorprese e con
questa bella immagine si conclude il
primo episodio di mille e shiro devo
dire che non è male me lo aspettavo
completamente diverso nel senso che a
parte la storia del padre non c'è una
vera e propria trama però gli elementi
ci sono tutti c'è il dramma familiare e
c'entra ma sportivo c'è il dramma del
fratello fisi cliché addosso e sono
solite cose
una cosa che mi è sempre piaciuta di
mila e shiro è il fatto che la
protagonista non fosse una sex symbol
che molto spesso fanno soprattutto
adesso le protagoniste femminili carine
non sexy per forza però sai belle in
modo che i piccoli ragazzini come me si
innamorassero di loro insomma sai quante
cose mi sono preso per le protagoniste
due mini dei cartoni animati e col mila
hanno fatto un personaggio che si è
intelligente sia ai suoi drammi ma è una
ragazza normale quasi tralasciando i
panda vaginali e quella è una cosa che
mi è sempre piaciuta per esempio
comunque questo era pausa è
semplicemente una mina o ed è tutto
molto più leggero del normale siamo
stravaccati vediamo quello che vogliamo
ed è tutto molto meno impostato grazie
mille per avermi seguite al prossimo
video
e buona l'acqua bollente d'estate